Here's a tip for your shell that will
have you navigate in all your directories
in literally zero time.
There's a tool written in Rust, obviously,
called Zocsight.
When enabled in your shell, you can type
z,
a partial directory name,
and it will take you there.
You can do this
no matter where you are, and it will
always
find
the right place. Let's find an extremely nasty
directory within my Rawkode Academy mono repository
for the Rawkode Studio project.
As you can see, that's quite a path
to remember.
Now sometimes there's ambiguity, Like if I go
to Dagger, it takes me to the Dagger
directory in my studio project.
However, Zoxides also allows you to use the
ZI
command.
This time when I run ZI Dagger, I
get to select
from all the options available.
Enjoy.